si l'on a souvent évoqué les
conséquences économiques de la pandémie
ou les conséquences psychologiques du
confinement
en voilà une qu'on n'avait pas forcément
vu venir bah oui des populations
confinées chez elles
on aurait pu penser que ça augmenterait
la tendance à faire des enfants
et bien c'est tout l'un verse on a
assisté durant ces derniers mois zco
qualifie de véritable baby crash en
janvier 2021 en france on a vu 13 % de
naissance en moins par rapport à janvier
2020 la chute de la natalité la plus
importante depuis la fin du baby boom
dans les années 70 autres chiffres en
2020 sept cent trente cinq mille
naissances
le chiffre le plus bas depuis la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale et ce n'est
pas qu'en france puisque en espagne
c'est pareil en italie le pays se
dépeuple carrément et aurait perdu 400
mille habitants en 2020 et si ce
vieillissement des populations en
occident venait à continuer cela
pourrait mener à une catastrophe
économique
on pense forcément au système des
retraites mais pas que certains secteurs
pourraient être fortement touché le
secteur de la petite enfance
l'alimentaire l'immobilier car les
familles déménagent principalement
lorsqu'elle s'agrandisse reste à savoir
maintenant si cette tendance va se
confirmer ou si certains attendent juste
des jours meilleurs pour faire des bébés